i'm a serious macaroni and cheese maker
that there's actually not a strong of
consensus about the relationship between
being overweight and being unhealthy
[Music]
all right turn me into c
[Music]
ready
oops
[Music]
[Music]
hey young man what's your name
um
can
how old are you
i'm i'm this many
oh wow would you like some candy
yeah good boy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and now he has to go to the bathroom
again that's whiskey
i'm kidding that's my mug i'm so sorry
it's just st patrick's day oh wow so
that's all happy st patrick's day
everybody remember today's live show
monday through thursday at 10 a.m
ish
if we're thrown off here you can catch
us on rumble uh you can catch us at the
blaze
podcasts you know whatever it's youtube
so we'll see if we can stay on i think
we should
but yeah join us at mug club what do you
think gerald i love mug club are you
saying hi to me now i am saying good
morning gerald happy saint patty's day
happy saint patty's day to you too baby
go irish so my my fighting irish won
last night in the uh i guess the first
games of the ncaa whatever basketball
thing okay that's enough all right
gibbon how are you i'm good how are you
sir
i'm doing good and how you doing kagan
michael key what's up baby tim the tool
man all right already got a healthy buzz
today oh there's oh nice that's good
good good we celebrate the day well yeah
how do we celebrate the irish yeah
of course
and i might i'm part irish i don't know
where they got the alcoholism thing from
and uh crawdaddy one of my favorite
people welcome to the show thank you
david thank you for coming in i'm
wearing it gerald why did they name a
football program after a race of folks
how did that happen how'd that get under
the radar the irish yeah the fighting
why wouldn't they well they they do
fight well it wasn't for that
everybody's like oh you got to change
the name because you think irishmans are
you know drunk fighting people no it was
actually they fought valiantly in
certain situations mostly in bars but
still it was valiant fighting effort
just last week after they've opened up
from coveted restrictions
there's so many bars that are going to
open today and be like i wish we just
stayed closed one more day i hated this
look at this bathroom just green vomit
pittsburgh steamer right yes well didn't
didn't don i must lose his job for
naming rudkers
yeah well he said that that one of them
yeah it was a word that now it wasn't
yeah
[Music]
curly like so
that wasn't the irish
no there weren't a lot of irish
basketball players i've never seen a
female irish basketball player you ever
see a ginger gal dunk
well i i i i could just say gal dunk and
that would be difficult there's a couple
that kind of seen a girl down yeah it's
just not often yeah dunkaroo's the one
who's in the soviet gulag could she dunk
oh yeah brittany griner
i don't even know who that is oh
the russians no no no she can't dunk i
don't think no okay she's only six eight
so yeah well yeah how many
how many wow what a big amazon what a
tall drink of water six eight yes and on
a woman that looks like eight four what
it does yeah
that's a terrifying height
i'd like the voice to go with it i just
would like to just go like on a date
with her not like for real but just so
people would stare and be like what what
is this table for two like hammer just
carry me to the table
there you go i'll need a booster seat to
make eye contact with her perhaps stack
them three high i'd like some crayons
please
you're gonna do it do it right dave
what's up
well so happy st patrick's day uh
nothing like waking up tomorrow with a
headache from binge drinking and a sore
throat from sitting at a bar and trying
to yell a conversation over the dropkick
murphys
they say
that st patrick's day is when you're
irish for a day but the day after when
you're hungover filled with regret and
not speaking to your friends and family
that's when you're truly irish for a day
and i say that as an irishman
uh personally one thing i love about st
patrick's day is this video we're about
to show i feel it's the greatest video
in the history of st patrick's day
well just in time for st patrick's day
crowds are coming by the dozens to get
an up-close view at what some say as a
piece of irish folklore some people in
the crichton area of mobile say a
leprechaun has taken up residence in
their neighborhood
nbc 15's brian johnson has more
curiosity leads to large crowds in
mobile's crichton community many of you
bringing binoculars camcorders even kids
you crazy people pictures to me it looks
like a leprechaun to me i gotta do look
up in the tree who else i found the pot
of gold
dude that ain't really
the leprechaun only comes out at night
if you shine a light in its direction it
suddenly disappears
this amateur sketch
the leprechaun looks like others find it
hard to believe and have come up with
their own theories and explanations for
the image my theory is casting a shadow
from
the other limbs
[Laughter]
don't be afraid
don't be afraid man
this guy helping to direct traffic is
right here
this is a special leprechaun flute which
has been passed down from thousands of
years from my great great grandfather
i just came to help out others just came
to get lucky in hopes a pot of gold may
be buried under this tree
uproot that tree i want to know what a
goal
i gotta go i already found it give me
the gold where i won't told you
news
people will do anything for a pot of
gold i mean anything you know what i
like i like the amateur sketch of the
leprechaun it looks like somebody got a
really good look at it and got that good
drawing who did that i want to know who
sketched that i don't know maybe brian's
dead
yeah
she wants to that was the sketch by the
way right there dave just uh recreated
them
yeah
yeah it had a hat
and a face of sorts
he disappears and you shine a flashlight
on it yeah it's not there yeah and the
whole neighborhood is out see it can't
you see it oh hold on oh he went he left
but that is uh actually it turned out to
be leprechaun in the hood with iced tea
so that was actually the inspiration for
that movie what's that scene right there
that i you know there are parts of
america
that just leave me
worried that i'm an american sometimes
yes well it's uh i think it's the best
video ever and today is a special day
it's 24 hours where we celebrate
the worst of the irish it's the bono of
holidays
so congratulations everyone
have a good day all right
what's up
[Laughter]
i meant specifically this studio i i'm
part irish let me redo crappy irish
things it is the snow patrol of holidays
oh come on there was one good song you
get out of here chasing cars come on oh
you put that suspenders around your neck
i want to know what happened the white
producer of that segment for that news
oh he was that guy
he's gone oh he's fired
the woman's just embarrassed yeah so
glad you you brought that up yeah
should people do anything for a pot of
gold it's like you don't even know what
to say when you say something like i
used to live in that neighborhood before
i became a news host yeah she's like
thanks for bringing me back and
reminding people of where i am anyway
hit so by this comment comment comment
guys smash that like like button if you
like leprechauns and also here's the
question of the day how will you
celebrate your saint paddy's day i'd
like to know will you safe and sober
yeah will you be getting drunk to
celebrate the irish perhaps hitting a
woman whatever it may be
putting a pair of irish sunglasses on
your old lady after a nice
day of binge drinking i'm irish i can
say it
you have irish street pass basically
yeah i got irish blood ah i'm half irish
the thing is you don't have to prove it
at all no you're a white person you can
say it yeah it's well it's the there's
no other holiday that we celebrate the
worst stereotypes of people
it's like during the mexican parade 13
of your family members rent an apartment
gerald threw on the green at the very
last minute i did yeah just embarrassed
for him he said notre dame alum vendors
he did he's got but i didn't even know
was saint patrick's day until last night
really no i was looking i was like oh
it's tomorrow i better mention that
better not drink look around the studio
no one else has green i feel like
patty mcdouche bag here well you shall
yeah well i want spinal tap and
i have a pot of gold
it's filled with i found it in a tree in
a very rough neighborhood that we have
uh also check out our merch store we got
a lot of merch stuff i may uh want to
recommend the ahoy shirt above all but
that's just me uh whatever you're taking
me plug it all no it's not shameless
whatsoever you can go to the merch store
and you can get some merch there you go
done you can look cool as us you know
with the the suspenders not so much but
you don't buy the suspenders no but
there's a gerald a shirt oh there isn't
oh people don't like him
all
i'll apologize after killing you how
about that that's fair okay as long as
it's to the corpse
i'm sorry i did this but you deserved it
let's wash you in the tub
all right so
i don't know if you guys know this the
oscars has three hosts this year
uh it's amy schumer oh lord uh wanda
sykes alec wanda
and uh regina hall
so you have three women there which i
have to be honest if it's just not adam
lambert and queen
i'm fine with it
that was are they trying to make people
not watch more than they already don't
watch i think they had a meeting and
we're like okay uh how can we not get
canceled this year and they were like
well let's have three hosts just in case
they fall like dominoes and they're like
okay well yeah two black
and then also
what if they're accused of a sex thing
let's make them all women that's that's
fine so this is i think their way
diversity uh but just trying to put a
host on without people getting in
where's regina hall does anyone you must
know she's an actress um she was in god
knows what
okay i don't know no that's not a title
she's in stuff she's she's a pretty lady
she was in watchmen watchman the show
which i didn't think was possible that
movie was terrible it was absolutely
horrific we were at the movie
transformers level and uh
you know when they have sex in the
spaceship
in the middle of the theater it opens up
and my wife just goes well that's gotta
stink
and the whole theater just bursts out
because it's true it's like you just had
sex after a sweaty fight in a tiny pod
gross
yeah i i like the comic book and then or
the graphic novel but the
well we have three hosts and after a
four year run with no emcee
this year's academy awards will feature
them because you have you know hosts we
had bands like the queen and adam
lambert which is just not queen because
there's no freddie mercury or my money
but they were able to find a guy who has
similar qualities to freddie mercury
he likes
i wha what do you what
what do you mean he likes huh i hear
he's uh huh
irish irish he's irish oh okay yeah yeah
that makes sense and that so i think
right now they're trying to be safe is
they don't want to just have the same
old oscar categories people get very
very offended yeah yeah so they've
decided to come out with uh
new oscar category solve the categories
you want to make it better so here we
are with seven plus one whoa
[Music]
sorry there's always one in the chamber
i don't mind
[Laughter]
i don't drink we can't even believe
steven entrusts us with this show
anything i know steven we are very sorry
we haven't done anything i believe to
get thrown off yet don't worry give me
time oh good apparently i'm the person
who gets us kicked off well let's talk
about the new seven plus one woke oscar
categories gerald it's gonna give me
number seven number seven most creative
skirting of covet regulations in a
production
number six
crawdaddy
best acting in a role that wouldn't have
existed even a year and a half ago
i've seen some of those number five give
me a geralt a number five bravest obese
person that's right period
in anything
anything at all anything at all it's a
person so it's not it doesn't cannot
offend you yeah it could be any kind of
person yes a number four we have
outstanding performance by an actress
that used to be an actor
number three crawdaddy character that
we'll have to be most apologized for
later
number two
gerald least obvious film pandering to
china ah that is a tough one that really
is you really gotta watch a lot of those
to figure out which one is best who's
gonna win you don't know you don't know
number one best supporting ally
and i think that's important
and of course we have a plus one
which is best actress who landed a role
and had to get an abortion due to
scheduling thank you that has been seven
plus one
[Music]
that means they pick their role over
life they did
priorities i don't know if you guys know
this i was actually in an oscar-winning
film once really
[Music]
well
what are you
i am a genie and i've been trapped in
this lab for over 4 000 years
now that you've released me i must grab
you three wishes anything that you
desire
anything
yes anything
anything at all three wishes friend go
ahead and tell me your first wish it is
my command
okay
suck my dick
what
oh i'm sorry that was an oscar winner
wow i thought it won an oscar does it
get better yeah i actually wish for two
more
that's the whole thing and canceled
[Laughter]
it's just i sexually assaulted genie i i
see a steven shaped hole through his
wall right now
running to the car it really is what
that genie really painted himself into a
corner didn't he did he did we did that
in 2012 sam tripoli's naughty show and i
figured bring it up
i had an acting reel but i didn't know
if it would be appropriate
so we we didn't uh we didn't use that
but this sort of thing brings us now to
this week in biden wait if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me or trump then you ain't black
so we established a new civil rights a
new civil rights cause of action
for those whose intimate images were
shared on the public screen
how many times have you heard i bet
everybody knows somebody somewhere along
the line that in an intimate
relationship
what happened was the guy takes a
revealing picture
of his naked friend or whatever in a
compromising position
and then literally in a sense black
males are
mortifies that person
send it out put it online if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me or trump then you ain't black
loyal boy your son is a photographer
it's not really yeah
anybody else he sent out a press release
saying please post this everywhere right
i i don't know he's like look i'm going
to be naked wearing an apron looking out
of my malibu window
would one of you escorts like to take a
photo of me what do you find up standing
ladies i'm reading a laptop from hell
it's a book about hundred bucks there's
a lot in there is it a real book it's a
real book laptop from hell laptop from
hell is that a thing yeah and it's even
got a picture of him on the cover with
the cigarette all ah crackled out was
this a smoking dijon
there is a movie coming out on this
called my
my son hunter is there really ann
mcelaney and um
her husband flims that clear is it woke
or is it people who did frac nation and
oh yeah they're so they're going to go
after good filmmakers oh it's a
documentary they did the gosnell movie
you remember that uh yeah yeah yeah so
it's not just kind of a remake of
scarface
pretty much though
very similar scenes they've got they've
got the uh the dope on this for sure
yeah i don't i mean i understand an
addict i gotta be honest right i
sympathize sit sympathize with it but
typically you just don't find them on
the board of burisma making tons of
money for the big guy well and
especially when like what was it three
years ago they had to fix his crack
teeth and they're like look you're sober
now and he's like all right all right in
front of a camera he's like yeah i'm
sober
i guess teeth is all i needed yeah no
it's been good i forgot my life together
at 53 or whatever all right so anyway
let's talk about this woke culture john
cleese uh asked i don't know if you know
john cleese uh he's from monty python
the original some you may not know him
and also the show faulty towers which i
think is one of the most brilliant
sitcoms ever
uh he
was at the south by southwest festival
and said that he thinks that brits
should get reparations oh really yes he
was on a panel i'd love it and uh after
was it
duel sloan
is that
ocean
who knows it's irish day dolce after
george's sloan from the daily show made
a joke about colonization yeah police
called the for reparations from greeks
and french
my people were slaves too you know
comedian right yeah yeah get competitive
well yeah he's hilarious get competitive
about this business of being oppressed
we were oppressed by romans for 400
years and then normans came over in
1066. they were horrible people from
france
we need reparations there too i'm afraid
at one point sloane confiscated the mic
temporarily from police i guess giving
it back jim gaffigan was there and said
what clee did was brave
and saying that well the thing is i'm
going to be dead and when cleese was
asked why he did this he said well the
thing is i'm going to be dead soon this
is why in favor of global warming i
don't want to be cold ever again
i love him uh in response to the uh the
hollywood report sorry in response to
the hollywood reporter article cleese
tweeted
next time the editor of the hollywood
reporter sends someone to review a
comedy festival he would do well to send
a reporter with a sense of humor
otherwise it's like sending someone deaf
to review a concert
that's how they're gonna get in trouble
it's called the triple down yeah
i love john cleese he's right though
he's greatest the idea that we're not
supposed to make jokes at south by
southwest which embraces
film art stand-up comedy yeah and
somebody from the daily show would like
you have no right to wrestle a
microphone from john cleese no like just
in a comedy hierarchy
oh yeah no you have no right was there
ever a monty python bit that wasn't
self-deprecating it was just slamming
the brits and their stiff upper lip and
it's always embarrassment oh they just
completely trash themselves
and i even the silly stuff is some of my
favorite like monty python and the holy
grail where they use coconuts instead of
horses
it was because they couldn't afford
horses budget worked
it did but there's a lot of
celebrities
sorry i've been drinking at st patrick's
day no you haven't i don't think no but
there have been a lot of celebrities
that have spoken out what i actually do
is i took allegra uh-huh and it's drying
my mouth have you tasted it yeah i had a
bit of allergies this morning ah and it
just feels like i spiked your drink did
you was gonna have time to tell you
i had some cotton balls in my mouth this
morning
mission accomplished i blew a muppet one
of these times so we have
celebrities who have spoken out though
about uh woe culture include ricky
gervais
we were gonna do an in memoriam this
year but when i saw the list of people
that had died it wasn't diverse enough
it just no
it was mostly white people and i thought
nah not on my watch this show should
just be me coming out going well done
netflix you win everything good night
but no no we got to drag it out for
three hours you could binge watch the
entire first season of afterlife instead
of watching this show that that's a show
about a man who wants to kill himself
because his wife dies of cancer and it's
still more fun than this okay
spoiler alert um season two is on the
way so in the end he obviously didn't
kill himself
just like jeffrey epstein
shut up i know he's your friend but i
don't care
apple roared into the tv game with a
morning show a superb drama yeah
a superb drama about the importance of
dignity
and doing the right thing made by a
company that runs sweatshops in china so
well you say you won't the companies you
work for i mean unbelievable apple
amazon disney if isis started a
streaming service you'd call your agent
wouldn't you so
if you do win an award tonight
pl don't use it as a platform to make a
political speech right you're in no
position to lecture the public about
anything you know nothing about the real
world most of you spent less time in
school than greta thundberg so if you
win right
come up accept your little award thank
your agent and your god and [ __ ] off
okay
i have to say
greatest speech in human history oh
absolutely i don't think anybody's ever
topped it yeah but it's very revealing
too though when you see a tom hanks kind
of
afraid
and then amy poehler who's just wedded
to nbc right and oh
well you hear the laughter and that's a
lot of the writers the kind of
people in the back yeah it's not the
stars they're like
every star is like well yeah i can't
react can you imagine being on camera
cook's table oh yeah she said about
apple and he just was like just look
down look at the menu or something like
fiddle
yeah
and all the wizards what's the order i
don't know
hey tim what are you gonna eat
crow
but all the wimps that scorsese's tip
hey tough guys over at scorsese's table
they're all we can't laugh at that come
on guys yeah just compliant you're just
a bunch of twerps well and you're also
digi we do mob moving you out on it so
you know it's also true yeah yeah that's
weird too dude bob toughness heroes
mob movies or we do uh children's movies
that's ridiculous
no you're right i think it's hilarious
though that they think that they're just
you see how when they get called out how
true it is by their body language like
you said when tom and i like tom hanks
sure he was just like yeah
yeah amy poehler can be funny but she's
like oh nbc signs the checks like that's
true i am owned by general electric
that's right did we fly on epstein's
plane to this award show or was that
last year oh you know there's several
people that have been on it they're like
well he wasn't my friend i mean i mean
he had a nice
ride that was a friend i'd say secret
keeper
i just had to be on a beach somewhere
he said i got an island i said perfect
perfect and he said filled with kids i
thought he meant i could bring the
family but i didn't
it's a lawsuit waiting to happen
i took a chance that's on me yeah so
also another actor he was actually
kicked out uh kevin hart was actually
kicked um off of the oscars because he
tweeted out uh if his son was gay he
would break a dollhouse over his head
and stuff like that
they decided to you know cancel him from
that but he wasn't permanently canceled
because they had to make jumanji
and they were like we need to we need a
black guy and they're like well how
about the rock and they were like well
he's already in it
so he got his career back he's tongan
yeah but dave he got his career back but
he had to do jumanji and jumanji too
welcome to the jungle
it's i've met kevin you've been a
punisher nice dude yeah yeah but i i
wasn't like hey i love your movies
here's kevin ours
and when the times of
we can cancel you by the way which is
the stupidest [ __ ] that i've ever
witnessed in my 40 years of life
the whole idea of i can kill you today
with it with the
click of a button in your life by the
way this is a real feeling that people
have yes
i'm in control of your life if i want
your life to stop and be over i'll
cancel you yeah and that means you can't
live no more this is how ridiculous it
is
it is true for people who say the cancer
culture doesn't exist they aren't
looking in the right places yeah because
there is a certain power given to people
on the internet who believe that they
can take away everything that you have
and the idea of wanting to destroy
someone completely is disgusting and the
amount of people that want to do it is
frightening well and everybody starts
acting out of fear right when he said
it's like sending a deaf person to cover
a concert i remember when uh one of the
oh one of the marvel movies came out and
had this great soundtrack to it i'm i'm
losing it uh guardians of the galaxy oh
yeah that was a great starting galaxy
two i think is the one that it was
specifically referencing and i can't
remember the actor that did this i think
it was chris pine and he said like crank
it up or something like that in a tweet
and basically had to go out and issue an
apology to the deaf community and end up
signing it if you remember that like he
actually ended up signing uh like just
signed using sign language to apologize
i'm like why are you apologizing it's
great music that you can hear it's not
like hey deaf people i know you can't
hear this ha ha that's not what he was
saying right but he's so scared of
getting cancelled because of that that
he had to do that it's insane you have
to say it's ridiculous it's not
ridiculous that's not the word it's
anti-freedom oh it's pro-establishment
yeah these people are the man
absolutely amazing and we all know
stevie wonder famous deaf piana player
wait what oh right
oh no he couldn't was three that was ray
charles so did you stevie wonder ray
charles was the devil
that's right and then there was mac
tonight for mcdonald's but he just lost
his vision from diabetes diabetes do you
remember mac tonight
mack tonight yeah no i don't he was
stevie wonder or well he wasn't steve
you said like ray charles it was a half
moon and he wore sunglasses and he sat
for mcdonald's i think i do yeah like
why is he blind and it's like heats
mcdonald's every day
what do you mean why yeah oh
self-explanatory
i don't know i there's a lot of
celebrities though that are against woe
culture and i think you know might be a
little bit uh what's the term
starts with the fired yeah i don't know
no no not really robert downey jr
somebody who's kind of based thank you
thank you there you go but you have
robert downey jr he's kind of said that
he's not an extreme liberal right and i
can understand that uh you have seth
macfarlane who i know is a liberal but
the jokes that he gets away with on a
cartoon series shows that he values
comedy yeah more than ideology which is
i think is somebody uh i think it's kind
of he's the guy who helped change bill
maher a little bit really yeah because
he would come on the show a lot and it's
i think it's important to be a comic or
to be funny
before it is
to be safe
because safety and comedy
sucks produces what we see in late night
and saturday night live honestly half of
snl looks like they just got notes from
the cia
and they're like okay so what do you
want today that's right
okay yeah that'll be a good sketch we'll
have yeah no laughs there wonderful
keegan can come in
keenan
then robert downey jr came to it through
experience he talks about it through his
expert you can't come through what i've
been through and not be more
conservative seth macfarlane's all about
the funny right he's just all about
comedy and yes some people don't like
him but if you watch one episode of
family guy even now
it's
offensive as hell and that's what's
funny about it and trey parker and matt
stone have never been anything but
really counter culture but extremely
popular
denzel washington is another one
actually do you think we've made any
headway
and i think it's more important to make
headway in our own house
by the time the system comes into play
the damage is done they're not locking
up seven-year-olds
yeah
you know i was in chicago a couple of
three four weeks ago
and we saw these little kids on bikes
with masks on the side of the head
like five or six of them and the driver
said yeah they little yummies i said who
said little yummies look up google a
little yummy
little yummy was 11 year old murderer
wow and you look at his picture you'll
see the head shot of him he's like this
and he got murdered at 11 by a 14 year
old wow who's doing life now and a 16
year old that makes no sense you blame
the system
where was his father
oh i mean it's a good point and here's
actually a picture of a little yummy
that's an 11 year old
ooh it's a tough 11 years so they're not
locking up seven year olds they're
locking up 11 year olds yeah chicago
yeah
well well he's dead he locked up the 14
year old
yeah but he's right
the kids in detroit don't have dads i
know it's very sad and i mean it comes
down to unfortunately a lot of
democratic uh
laws and stuff that they put forward to
build kind of a welfare system well and
the inability to say something that's
true and
not be afraid right because it look i
don't care what the the race is that
we're talking about the person i have no
i i could care less
i could see a stat sheet and just look
at it and go hey anytime there's not a
father in the home it's a problem so
let's address that issue let's address
that issue to the best of our ability
and if it affects one community more
than another so be it that's fine i'm
not making a statement on the community
i'm not trying to say see we're better
than you i'm just saying that's life's
problem applies to anybody that has yeah
but anybody that says it yeah oh and
there's plenty but it takes a denzel
washington
saying that he can say it
could you can say because you're irish
well yeah i'm irish well it's it's
my dad's dad left the day he was born
well happy st patrick's day
irish we were the original scumbag
fathers
we were here before you i've never met
my grandpa
i heard it i didn't oh i'm sorry i
didn't i met my guy who raised him
that's who was my grandpa i never met uh
timo olive for cigarettes
but honey i'm giving birth i know i
really need a smoke yeah i got to go
though yeah yeah i'm gonna go get
somebody else pregnant
go on for some potatoes swack the
yes i'm gonna go get myself some french
fries and impregnate another [ __ ] i
feel like my job is done here
i've been a father for eight minutes
that's all you need okay bye-bye yeah i
think in any community that's part of it
and the problem is you're maybe there is
a systemic
because of a systemic problem because of
what democrats have put in place
especially in detroit i totally
understand there's a systemic thing to
blame but you have to fight
the right system right you can't just
fight this whole narrative that cnn and
all these other shows are telling you
that that's what you should believe is
it's this entire group of people that
hate you right it's not the reality
that's right no and i think something
that i was talking to a friend yesterday
at lunch i said mo some people don't
know where we come from on when we when
we go after like a test holiday or when
we go after somebody on on the left for
doing something that we we vehemently
disagree with we're not going after
somebody who's overweight right we're
not going after somebody who's having a
problem with gender identity or
something like that we're going after
people who say that those things are
healthy and good and that kids under age
should be given things that will alter
their life forever right we're going
after people who say sexualization in
the classroom for a five and six year
old is totally appropriate that's what
we're going after we're going after
people trying to make it it takes some
intellect to get the humor yeah the left
test suspend that really to to you know
take us on for it right they're ignoring
the fact that we're using humor to to
highlight those points well sometimes
that's the only way you can get it
across if you don't point out what's
funny about it it's kind of hard for
people to grasp it as being ridiculous
this idea of marrying women to the state
for a check
and
a man better not be in the household
that's how this got started absolutely
yeah and
it was it was not good to have a guy
around well no and that's what sucks is
you dangle money in front of somebody
who's poor i mean a lot of people i
don't know what it feels like to be poor
buy votes from a group of people yeah
and it's sad and i mean you look at
somebody like denzel who excelled in his
field worked very hard and is arguably
the best living actor i'd probably say
you know really the top five yeah
yeah i mean if he's in a movie i'm gonna
watch it yeah so you know i think he's i
think it's good that he makes that point
and that's not a racist point that's a
point i think he's making out of love
and experience
just my opinion yeah
there's also the solid opinion david
thank you very solid yes thank you i
like to be
rock hard great
gigantic opinion dave giant throbbing
opinions here's what i what interview
with the griot
what
he gave an interview with the griot
which i have no idea what that is but i
don't either publication of sorts that
was the one right and uh do you want me
to read the quote there thank you go
ahead yeah i'll read the quote it starts
in the home if the father is not in the
home the boy will find a father in the
streets i saw it in my generation in
every generation before me and everyone
sense if the streets raise you then the
judge becomes your mother and prison
becomes your home
that is i'll say it though as somebody
who like i didn't lose my dad since i
was 18 but
he was out of the house a lot for
surgeries and stuff starting at 14.
right so my mom wasn't there and i did
turn to the streets yeah i turned the
streets and i became a drug addict and i
was in a lot of violent situations and
it was it's dangerous to be in that it's
like i had a very good upbringing and a
very loving home and sometimes there's
just stuff that you can't help
and it's like i i have sympathy for a
lot of people but it's like you have to
you have to fight it you have to keep
pushing yeah absolutely so um but more
on that later so if a bad seed like you
yeah make it then
yeah there's hope for everybody look if
a scumbag like me yeah can pull himself
up by the bootstraps tell me more i've
done stuff that i'm right
it haunts me every day have you
apologized uh i thought we call it make
amends make amends and i have made
amends with a lot of people although i
did see one girl i didn't like it wasn't
a like
i i drunk drive i was drinking and
driving and i hit her car and drove away
anyway so i saw her
years speaking of drunk driving did she
heal i mean she wasn't in it
it was that story where there was oh yes
a bow on it
oh the christmas oh christmas birthday
whatever yeah but i didn't see it
wrapped in a bowl
horrible there's a lot of people
there's
there's so many people i have to
apologize for i just don't have the time
to find them
but i've done most of it can you do a
mass apology like hey i probably did
something yeah if you knew me more of a
class-action apology if you knew me when
i was drinking and you're not one
specific cop i'm very sorry
if you are that cop i am not sorry i'm
not sorry
he was a prick who the other cops hated
hated him we all feel we know this cop
yeah you you know oh he's the worst
i just want to say his name and be like
you can't i know because you get sued
well
is he still in the force i don't know i
hope not i i could do some research i
hope it was a
i hope he was uh i don't want to say no
i hope he was fired fired for being bad
at his job there was one cop though that
was a
kind of a jerk and he uh beat his wife
and they pulled a gun on her and i was
like hi the guy arrested me how you like
them apples oh he got arrested yeah
then he was your cellmate yep yeah well
and he meetings continued he found a new
wifey
so it's
yeah he uh honey i'm home yeah but other
than that guy huh he threw me down a
staircase and helped me with night
sticks
wow yeah did you guys deserve it no i
was hiding in a closet stop resisting
and i haven't been for years did you
deserve it
no i i was hiding in a closet because i
don't want to get arrested again
and my friends
this is a good saint patty's day
drinking story it may have even been
saint patty's day to be honest with you
i was hiding in a closet underneath a
pile of clothes at my brother's
girlfriend's house
and the police came in the room but
there was another girl hiding it was
like this nerdy hot girl and she's like
and all i hear is like she's like is
anybody here i'm like i am she's like
who is it i'm like a pile of laundry
shut up nobody needs to know we're in
here
so the cops come in and they drag her
out from under the bed like the movie
taken
[Laughter]
and then they don't say now they're gone
it's been like 15 minutes and uh
somebody walks in and i go who's there
and it's the same cop who goes i am and
then the cops pulled the laundry off me
like i was e.t
and uh walked me to the edge of the
stairs
and shoved me down the staircase oh well
while a sea of white people chanted and
some black people were there too
obviously but detroit but it's it was
mostly white people
chanting rodney king rodney king rodney
king and they're all like you saw that
he fell and they're like no no you did
everybody's like nah you shopping we all
watch no smartphones no no cameras no
body cam on the cops threw me down the
stairs i got arrested in the car i was
able to get the girl's phone number by
the way
really yeah i was like you're like you
know i like the cut of your jib you were
arrested you got thrown downstairs
you're my guy i always had a pen and it
was not to write it was to clean out
bowls
so
i pulled that out and she was cuffed in
the front i was cuffed in the back and
she wrote her number on the back of my
hand so then when i explained what
happened to my my mom she's like well
we'll just call everybody and turns out
nobody was at the party it was just me i
was just you yeah just me and uh she did
get off actually because she's rich and
i was charged with minor in possession
and attending an underage drinking party
huh did you get a date at all no i
called and the dad goes who is this and
i said my name
i and he goes the one that was arrested
with my daughter and i go yeah and he
goes don't ever call here again and he
hung up and i was like ah i'm gonna miss
so
hiding in dirty laundry is not
considered evading a rest
uh they didn't charge me with it oh only
if you're quiet it's okay yeah once
you've you once they throw you down the
stairs they're kind of like ah we can't
charge them with everything i wouldn't
have said who's there that's fine for
another day and a half why did you yeah
you had to call out well i was hammered
he was still drunk and he thought i must
be safe now it's been three seconds to
be honest i i wanted something to drink
hey speaking of st patrick's day news um
this comes from angela breaking news
from the edit bay so that leprechaun
that we talked about earlier in the show
we actually found in chicago really and
it's none other than uh chicago mayor
glory oh boy oh my goodness
i knew it was her
e.t oh boy i think she could look better
but that green bowler that sets it off
oh she grants wishes but it doesn't come
true the way you think it would
it becomes a real nightmare
people in chicago are just hoping not to
die on st patrick's day by being shot is
her
it's me the black leprechaun
welcome to chicago enjoy getting hit by
a bullet driving through here's your
bulletproof yes it's hell here look at
that whimsical green river yes have you
seen you had all the murders a lot like
that
our murder rate has gone up it is led
it's not russians though all the bodies
floating in the green river
ah they have green blood i love that too
they're like is the green river hurting
is the putting the green into the river
hurting the environment it's like
there's bullet casings everywhere yeah
let's not worry about dying yeah you're
focusing on food dye really right it
would be green anyway just from the
vomit actually it's normally red but uh
yes
[Music]
we put some blue in it maybe
who cares if it's green there's a lot of
i don't even know if there are irish in
chicago anymore yes of course there are
ah there's none i read it i went to the
saint patty's day parade in cleveland
they're not over there too are they
still doing the parades yeah so now that
covet is kind of subsiding yeah they're
like come on out and pretty much and i'm
not sure why the irish decided to settle
in the wonderful places you made it to
the the land of the free and the home of
the brave and you chose pittsburgh and
cleveland
it's just still the third largest
country i'll bet dallas overtakes it in
the next set oh yeah yeah probably i bet
uh yeah i wonder what the floats for the
parade are like just a giant alcoholics
anonymous book
another one's just a guy binge drinking
another guy leaving his family one guy
just hitting a woman two dudes in a bar
fight you're like this is the most
racist holiday imaginable fantastic i'll
go get another drink come see my meat
meat and potatoes yes oh wow this is a
potato diamond float where they ate the
babies
get a load of my chalet yes they had to
eat their pets and their loved ones all
right
this is the five corners
if you say that after it makes it
it's more racist than anything i just
thought of hey what's irish sugary
cereal with a leprechaun on it yeah so
much oh boy yeah
never liked it i was more of a captain
crunch guy but that's you know before
your time i guess wasn't
i like the was it horseshoes
marshmallows empty whiskey bottles what
were they
prison
and regrets
paddy wagons
another entirely racist term that a lot
of people don't realize
yeah the paddy wagon is because of the
irish
all right so tell you this though i'm
excited to announce this yeah steven
crowder the host of this show who's out
today planning a change in my mind yeah
baby uh he and i will be on tour go to
louderwithcrowder.comtour
you can also see me a uh friday april
8th at the ralto theatre in juliet
illinois
at joliet whatever it's called juliet
joliet illinois on saturday april 9th
and the hennessey theater
the genesee theater in waukegan illinois
come out to those shows it's going to be
a lot of fun and also i'm on this new
thing called shout out it's an app where
like you can uh
you wish birthday it's like
say hi yeah you wish happy birthday uh
merry christmas happy divorce well i
don't sorry about
uh sorry about buying smelling your kid
whatever you want to put on there
there's lots of fun people on there
including myself and i just thought i'd
mention that yeah
i wanted to mention the dates too may
14th in tulsa oklahoma there's still a
handful of tickets left for that and
then we added that second show in
colorado springs because you guys the
pikes peak uh theater yeah we actually
were able to add a second show that is
the popularity of steven's get it done i
know i'm just on the coattails baby
comedy's funnier at altitude it is it's
true yeah well yeah marijuana's legal
there too
so i smelled it everywhere i was in when
i was in colorado i know what wait oh no
my stars
i didn't know i lived in boulder for a
little while did you really yeah i don't
remember much
well that's just because you walked
outside and took a deep breath i may
have started the fires in uh 2000
rocky mountain high means something a
little different now i guess it was very
dry there and you shouldn't flick
cigarettes onto dry well especially not
repeatedly dave like why we're not
lighting them and flicking them a lady
stopped my car and my friend was driving
and just reamed me and i was like i'm
sorry i didn't know the whole thing was
kindling well and then later it was
burning but i'm like that couldn't have
been me
that's a coincidence yeah no big deal
speaking of uh
hurting people
mike tyson and marijuana uh-huh uh
that's what i should have segwayed with
marijuana i was setting you up i should
have gone hurting people mike i like
mike tyson
just i just want to say that so he
doesn't hurt me the 2022 mike tyson
wonderful very soft oh you don't like
the 1988 fresh out of the ghettos
beat you until you scream jump for that
old uh
make orphans out of his children yeah do
you remember the uh
well what was it it was the other old
rob schimmel joke because it used to be
uh
like would you take a punch for mike
tyson for a million dollars
no he's like he's like for a million
dollars i would fellate him in front of
my parents
no the answer is no no i would not i
well i'd take him out for mike tyson for
a million dollars never oh i would i'd
be dead it would cut exactly that's my
point it'd be brain bleeding but i could
leave my child with something ah yes we
just talked about fathers dave
well
i've been there i've been there for most
of it yeah but
you've only gone out for a pack of
cigarettes twice no that's i haven't
smoked in 10 years buddy thank you ever
since i had my first kid i don't
acknowledge mike tyson is launching a
new marijuana edible called tyson bites
shaped like ears it just makes common
sense i hope they're shaped like holy
field tears well they no they even have
little bites taken out of them oh do
they really are you serious
i bet it is the strongest marijuana in
the entire world it's probably not even
marijuana and it's probably got like a
delay so that you eat another one and
like it just didn't happen no it didn't
work and then later like what is oh look
at that
how pissed does holy feel those look
more like wrestler ears yeah they really
do yeah like the the cauliflower yeah oh
my god oh that's so gross no offense if
you have cauliflower here but i don't
want to look at you you definitely do
not want to offend people with gold are
you joking those are the last
i have good friends with cauliflower
many of my friends cauliflower-eared
friends yeah but could you not wear the
protective plastic things they have that
make you look like even more of an idiot
what if you're sitting there wrestling a
man in a leotard you want to look gay
hold on make sure you get to full mount
yeah it's a full mount i'm not wearing
those ear things though that's a full
mountain stick your hooks in that looks
ridiculous i'd love to go north south
with you let me grind on a high school
competitor
it's funny that all the janitors come
out to watch our practice yeah
and it's a sport they measure in riding
time
i i love uh fake wrestling
like yeah i've never ever liked it oh
i'm good you're offending brought again
right now why oh yeah real wrestling
brought again loves debbie so do i i'm
going to uh
wrestlemania for the first time this
year really i've been to smackdown have
you i'm taking my son to wrestlemania
can we so these are different smackdown
and wrestling yeah different titles
different type wrestlemania is the
biggest event that was the one that was
at like the pontiac silver dome yeah
they actually went to that i saw andre
the giant i saw andre the giant fight
uh hulk hogan yeah in detroit yeah the
final time or
it was not a pontiac though i think it i
think it was at uh joe lewis arena or
cobo hall i think no the silver dome
okay was that it was a silver dome yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah i mean they might have that
download it's
but they did the wrestlemania two or
three was done the pontiac silver number
wow that's still the record i think
still terrible it was still like the
biggest watch one and then yeah andre
the giant would drink like two-fifths
and jack the snake talked about how he
had three fifths one day and he fell
backwards and he was supposed to just
kind of not land on jake the snake's
chest but instead he landed directly on
jake the snake's chest which destroyed
every bone in his body oh wow and that's
how he got addicted to painkillers well
then he became a real snake like you get
rid of the bones and you can move
yeah well he said he didn't one of the
funniest things he says i saw him do it
the show live and he's like i didn't
like snakes
and he's just covered in snake bites and
he kept
he kept letting him loose in diamond
dallas's paige's house
like try to get him sober so like every
three weeks he's got to rip out his
walls to find a boat inspector because
the crack head in one of the rooms can't
keep a snake in the back
[Laughter]
you know brought against weird he he
likes the fake wrestling but he likes
ufc too which is completely real yeah
that's totally real well i mean there's
definitely a very realness to wrestling
i mean that's some rock hard mats that's
something oh no the athleticism you have
to acknowledge anyone's ever played a
sport these guys are serious athletes i
don't care if the fight is fake but yeah
very good athletes yeah chris benoit had
the brain of an 80 year old 80 year old
alzheimer's patient when he took his uh
family out yeah oh which is just
slightly smarter than joe biden
look out jill speaking of smart people
oh please if he was going to go after
anybody hunter
anyways
every time he sees a picture of bo wrong
kid dad um oh what
you don't agree
all right
let's talk about meth
and florida like i needed to say let's
talk about math like when i said meth
you didn't immediately think florida uh
this is fun
have you done meth no no
ever i've seen breaking bad though so i
feel like i know you want to do
something no
i got a recipe no glass please you sure
none right
i'm pretty good at it have you done meth
i haven't you know in my day mescaline
was the thing what was it what was
mescaline was it no no from
like an acid thing yeah that was the
yeah the rage in my high school peyote
is a cactus masculine is uh i forget
what it was but yeah we used to do
masculine that was fun oh yeah we
brought it up for you now yeah yeah
terrible oh those are good days no no
dave they were though those were thrown
down the stairs days no that was drunk
oh when i was on a trip i enjoyed my
time
terrible not all the time when i tripped
for seven days i didn't that's a
different story altogether
i thought i i don't know if i came back
from it or just got used to it
who knows
anyway
according to her
is this hernandez according to hernando
county sheriff's office thomas eugene
calucci
made an emergency call last thursday to
have his meth tested for authenticity
the man called 911
to make sure his crank was real
apparently this good samaritan told
deputies
he wanted it tested because he did not
want other people to purchase the fake
meth can you imagine that would be chaos
deputies happily obliged the sheriff's
department said if a person has any
doubts about the authenticity of any
illegal narcotics you have on
hand or have obtained from another
person the hernando county sheriff's
office is pleased to provide this
service
free of charge
but he was irish and so it's totally
fine i just love that that this isn't
the first time there was actually
another guy it was a cop who took weed
brownies from an evidence locker yeah
and then he's on the phone like i'm so
hot i think i'm gonna die like he called
the cops on himself
after eating weed from an evidence
locker
but that brings us to today's sponsor
hold on it's over
opioids
after i blew up my knee playing high
school football i never thought i'd live
pain-free ever again
giving birth to triplets and injuring my
back getting rear-ended by a drunk
driver i figured soreness and irritation
were just a part of life
i just needed to escape the daily hell
that i call life
oh
and i had some minor foot pain
[Music]
i think that's the guy that rear-ended
me
yeah
it is
after my fourth dui i was court-ordered
to never drink again and now i have a
scram tether that monitors my alcohol
intake 24 7.
but then my doctor told me about opioids
he said they'd take my pain away for
good
and now i don't suffer because i got a
bottle of 60 warm hugs from god
now that i don't have any pain i can
catch anything that life throws at me
i don't hurt anymore and now my three
kids have a hard time keeping up with me
when i run out of my medicine the agony
returns and then i have to do pretty
sinful things to get more
there's only supposed to be one of you
guys
my doctor said i'm too pretty to get
addicted
opioids should only be used as medically
prescribed they may cause nausea
headache constipation anal discharge
crocodile tears addiction cult leading
hair lips suicide homicide clowning
around with the fellas and in rare but
fairly often cases death
ask your doctor about opioids today
opioids
because you're not on heroin
yet
[Music]
opioids now available in chewable
tablets be sure to keep them around the
house if you have young ones with a
loosen top next to your gun
all right listen now we're back
by the way if you ever have a problem
with any stolen opioids or somebody
else's prescription and you want to know
if it's real genuine product just call
the police yes that's the best thing to
do it for you absolutely or just take it
no don't take it there's a good way to
identify if it's fake it's if you're
high or not
just throwing it out there we take them
for uh pain we get it yes and buy
prescription only though you know what
the opposite of pain is what's that me
at the hartford funny bone this weekend
[Music]
shameless shameless shameless
shameless the cash register
but seriously come on i'd love to meet
the fans i like you guys yeah i like
you're giving out free opioids yeah
don't say that you know there will be a
line the tickets will sell out right now
well i'd like to welcome to the show
laying the brain
thanks glad to be back
ah i can't hear you at all just leaning
glad to be back you should lift up did
you comically put it this low from him
one of these things will have a budget
for a real audio guy that's set up for
me you're a tall glass of water
yeah i'll just project there you go
right here there you go excellent it's a
sailing reference anyway thanks for
having me back i do appreciate it i
appreciate you coming on my friend carol
thank you for letting me return you know
after last time's performance i think
you needed a minute so i just wanted to
make sure guys i was the one that needed
let's keep it friendly right
darren and i we can just go into detroit
stories i think it's too heavy
russian and taiwan documents that's what
we're going to talk about yeah an
alleged russian intel league claimed
that china had planned a fall
invasion of
i should read these before
before russia's invasion of ukraine let
me read that again more professionally
and a legend russian intel league
claimed that china had planned a full
invasion of taiwan before russia's
invasion of ukraine
wow thank you basically was this china
being a little pissed off at russia that
they beat them to the punch
probably yeah sort of i mean from what i
can tell the the foreign ministry in
taiwan can't
actually back up that this document is
legitimate the source is legitimate but
they haven't confirmed this is run in
newsweek right as a story yeah this just
ran yesterday so we can totally trust
that it's 100
no it's and it's it's that the
speculation was just a little more
interesting the conversation that i
brought up not necessarily that we're
saying this is
absolutely true well yeah the document
is said to be written by an anonymous
analyst with russia's
federal security service
calling himself wind of change is that
wasn't like the first ship
isn't wind of change a song yes what
there is what's the find the wind of
change i want to know why they call
themselves this i feel like that it's
not even like a threatening that
legitimize it to me because that sounds
like a name like a russian would come up
with it really yeah oh they're like this
is cool the westerners like names he's
like we are spin doctors
[Laughter]
wins have changed yeah it's like 80s or
90s it's very yeah i think it's very
ballady it is is it it's like i know the
song in my head
something yeah it's by uh beans yeah
scorp well there's a but it's their
ballad right
yeah
all right
[Music]
this is when the androgynous look should
have stopped right yeah
[Music]
of chains
beautiful i know the song i told you
well yeah scorpions yeah i just didn't
know that i didn't know it was the i
forgot it was i don't know that word at
donkey kong or donkey conker what is he
saying i think i'm gonna go see them
live as soon as i get free tickets at a
gas station
[Laughter]
you get your time machine to go back and
see them when they're at their peak oh
yeah yeah yeah that's the one i'm gonna
pick scorpions wow they've shut the
coupon off the back of a milk carton
they're rocking like a hurricane right
yeah uh no they are how dare you the
rocket like a hurricane is how dare you
that's white snake right no that's
scorpion rock me like a hurricane a
scorpion yeah wow you're right i feel
like we're being a little judgmental
here no no i wouldn't
that's what that's you like a hurricane
rock you well now
it's semantics no it's semantics it's
the song what was the best hockey song
the great white was the band that was
like hey i don't think we need a fire
exit
all right
[Laughter]
[Applause]
or this asbestos curtain behind us
totally fine let's keep that there
look who plays a 200-seater and goes
pyrotechnics is going to be a good idea
there's one exit yeah well let's see if
everybody can fit out at the same time
oh no i guess the band can leave though
sure you're permanently scarred from
burns but you got to see white snakes
it's a trade-off so hey lane so talk
talk to me a little bit more about this
story right so people are saying that
china had a plan to invade taiwan this
fall but that plan kind of got derailed
by russia invading ukraine why why would
that derail the plan if china really
wanted to go at taiwan in the fall
um i don't think it's necessarily saying
it derailed it other than
it
from what i'm gathering from the
document and from how the chinese
responded to the invasion is what
they've been seeing so far has made them
reconsider any plans that they might
have had
would like by ukrainians holding their
ground yes because uh are they that
worried that their military can't
perform so i think what has probably and
what has probably
i guess unnerved the chinese the most is
seeing kind of the western unified
response to
the ukraine situation right and that's
not a military intervention but it's
every single country in europe north
america well canada the united states
and then the eastern european or eastern
asian countries like
south korea taiwan everyone's on the
same page right and i don't think china
really
saw that kind of
uh cohesive response happening
i don't think that they thought that was
happening okay but they are seeing that
they're not doing anything right
militarily like russia is still there
fighting now they say that the attack is
stalled but they're not the world is not
like sending
like their their soldiers right and
again i think this is kind of a
point that you would think okay the
united states the west isn't doing
anything that makes china realize oh
well we can get away with doing what we
want now i would actually argue the
opposite and say
that this is actually showing a lot of
restraint on the us's part
because i think they understand
that we have to allocate resources and
those need to be allocated towards asia
because it's just much more important to
us i have no doubt
and i think hold on hold on is this like
so is this the minister of foreign
affairs did we say this already joseph
wu said he couldn't of yeah couldn't
authenticate
yeah i don't care what you're talking
about you might as well be speaking
french
said he couldn't authenticate the
document but hey pops crowder the stance
of the biden administration does that if
you're a world leader does that make you
think twice or are you like this guy's a
weakling is it weekly yeah so i i i
think everyone agrees i understand where
you're coming from but i don't know that
china is making any changes based on the
global response to ukraine because i i
get that financially it can hurt people
if they
i think both things can be true though
biden can be weak but
the world response is very real i mean
people it is for sure yeah almost trying
to
fill a void where biden right biden is
left yeah but this so i think this is a
little bit different story so i agree
and disagree with you at the same time
right so i agree in that you're right
the world response does have some kind
of an impact but this is china saying
taiwan left us
basically just seceded from china
essentially originally that's that's
essentially what happened right they're
in china that's not what happened in
their minds that's what the communist
party
that's what they're saying happen right
so that would be the story that they
would put to the rest of the world and
all we're doing is taking back what is
ours that's not what's going on really
as as much in russia ukraine they
there's obviously the former soviet
union and i understand that and there's
there's russian-speaking people in kind
of the eastern part or people that maybe
identify more with russia and ukraine
right but he's not going back over there
just to say ukraine needs to be reunited
he's going back over there because he
thinks he needs a buffer between them
and nato sure right so it's a little
different story right so right i don't
know that chyna looks at this and goes
ah well we were gonna do this because
economically china can put the screws to
the world russia cannot
true but i
i think there was an interesting tweet
that came out yesterday i actually sent
this to given that
really goes to my point i think what
china would have liked to see happen
more than anything is the united states
to get involved militarily in this
conflict i think that would have been
their eye
because what does that do it bogs down
the united states military it takes
resources it takes attention it takes
focus away from what would be their
theater which is the south pacific yeah
but u.s military doctrine is sorry south
china sea seeing readiness doctrine is
saying we can fight full-scale iraqi
wars iraq size conflicts at the same
time that's our readiness doctrine from
the last time that i saw it right so we
should be able to do something like that
we should also be able to kill dave for
drawing me
with the hat on but anyway i think i
didn't draw a hat i think we understand
we've had this concern about taiwan for
a little while you think the world
response is slowing down china i think
it may a little bit but if they want to
go
they're going to go yeah
right
i agree they're going to go anyway but i
think they're going to have to delay
whatever that timetable was and figure
out a few more things well they're going
to do it sometime in the next 20 years
well for sure and this is this is
actually interesting because ukrainian
people a lot of times we're standing and
fighting but a lot of people had to be
ordered to stay the men but according to
new polling 70 percent of taiwanese are
now willing to stay and fight for their
country and that which is pretty good
right up from 30
compared to a poll administered before
russia's invasion of ukraine so maybe
maybe that made it a little harder where
they're like yeah we're gonna have we're
gonna have to fight for it and so maybe
now china's like well if 70 are going to
stay and fight i mean we'll just we'll
just keep stealing technology and be
fine over here i was just guessing
darren but it turns out and i agree but
i think we get the chinese psyche from
this tweet i want to read it real quick
if you could pull that back up because
it's really interesting um this is from
the global times the journalist at the
global times can you read it in mandarin
forest uh i think it's written in
english because
they're you know the global times is an
english propaganda outlet but
after zielinski's speech to congress
yesterday and the congress got up and
clapped you know everything i can you i
can't put it back up yeah thank you so
the the the global times responded no
just applause it's hypocritical if the
u.s really wants to show justice it
should send troops to ukraine or at
least set up a no-fly zone and fight
putin's troops directly even if that
means the sacrifice of u.s soldiers
don't just incite ukrainians to die for
american interest why would they be
pushing why
[Music]
exactly i think they want people to turn
against the united states
sure they also would want the united
states to be busy doing something full
resources
i just don't think i just don't like i
know you said our readiness doctrine
says we should be able to fight two wars
like iraq but we didn't at the same time
and we couldn't even fight the one at
the same time and win it so what makes
us think we could fight a europe the two
next
troop deployment sizes we weren't trying
to like take over a country in iraq if
we wanted to take over the country and
win the war we should have done that we
were just trying to rebuild their
economy and be nice guys as steven said
we have done forever right that was that
of taking the right that was against
third-rate goat herders in the middle
east now we're talking about several
weeks you're right yeah now we're
talking about russia and china the two
next biggest militaries in the world so
i don't know why we would think we
should be able to fight both those
fronts china knows that being a goat
herder so i agree i completely agree
with darren biden is weak this isn't
defending him at all
but they're all right hopefully we will
have at least some into i'd like to
think there's some intelligent people
left in the government somewhere i know
that's a stretch of the imagination it
really is yeah but i i agree with you
i'd like to see that i mean that's the
dream it's like two or three could you
guys make it more obvious that you're
still there please oh me no no oh yeah
oh there's none
well if they're being yelled over yeah
there's no way
well i hope it doesn't happen because i
do think that and you've said this too
if if china does go into taiwan you've
even felt that they've been emboldened
by this previously um that they would
they would be more apt to go into taiwan
after seeing the response to russia
going into ukraine without sending
troops right
if that happens that everybody says
world war iii is potentially now i think
that's definitely yeah it is much more
of a catalyst for world war three than
this situation we mentioned it in this
last thing i'll point out just about how
much more important it is like
everything in here there's a
semiconductor in it right right well i
think
every i mean
those are pretty high tech looking so i
mean they're nice yeah they're top-down
i've made them they're snappy taiwan
controls 63 of the semiconductor market
in the world and tsmc one company
controls over half of all semiconductor
production in the world and that's
probably outside of food the most
important resource that exists food and
oil i would say okay so so is china
attacking taiwan bad terrible okay got
it all right worse than russia attacking
ukraine i feel like i won again so
really i don't know how you can think
that but that's first
this is devil gerald with uh goatee
i see gerald world war can be fun it
really can especially if you have now if
i shine a flashlight on that will it
disappear it might it might
you have no idea what i could draw on
this
all right so we should probably wrap it
up uh because no i honestly yes uh yeah
and what do i have a question for both
of you let's say a taiwan kid uh-huh uh
taiwanese kid super hero kid captain
america in taiwan i'm taiwan kid what
are you here to do captain still
computers have sex with businessmen for
life
that's thailand
oh right
all right so um
taiwan though is what john cena said
didn't exist yeah well that's what china
says is part of china right so the world
can't recognize them the who can't
recognize them we can't recognize their
independence if we accept a gift from
them or there's just so many things we
do we've actually sent the fleet
to the straits many times to
ward off conflict to let right now that
we wouldn't let something happen i'm not
sure how many times we've actually gone
through it my question is far less
intelligent what i'm wondering is if
uh there's a
taiwanese boy uh-huh and they're
ladyboys that's thailand again thailand
a taiwanese boy though yeah
who lives in the taiwan ladyboys silence
taiwanese saint jude's okay i don't know
saint rude's maybe they call it would
john cena show up if his wish was to
meet john cena or we'd pretend that the
country didn't exist he would pretend
the country didn't exist and he would
issue an apology for the boy asking for
him yeah to comment oh i think that's a
good thing to reverse john cena he'd be
like i can't see you
yeah
and see that is how we find common
ground and listen i wish i couldn't see
john
cena well ever ever ever again oh he's a
great question not good and all those
things thank you for coming in lane i
appreciate it
but let's keep having him back i agree i
love when he comes in give a round of
applause come on guys
yeah the kids love him okay thank you
thank you thank you for coming who looks
like hitler's wet dream oh he is
[Laughter]
and by hitler i mean me
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay so anyway uh you should go
subscribe to mug club honestly it's not
that much money uh you're not
you're better you're better than what
you think you are it's a great way to
support the show and you know that the
tech overlords don't really like us and
you get some extra content we get to say
all kinds of really offensive stuff
behind the paywall yeah it's really dave
i like that mostly silly games
silly games really it's a lot of fun go
behind the paywall and also thank you
for watching today we're gonna go to mug
club um but please comment comment
comment hit the like button that's how
we are able to get this show out and
about
thank you again happy saint paddy's day
be safe don't drink and drive too late
and uh
ever ever ever i'm joking it's a joke
if i yeah i guess you have to i hate
that all of youtube is i have to say
it's right well you're scared of getting
canceled yeah
who knew well i'm canceled already i'm
just afraid of getting banned all right
so anyway piss off youtube
you